Récemment le moteur d'un Boeing
777 explosait en plein vol.
Heureusement il n'y a pas eu
de victimes. Mais imaginons
un matériau qui s'inspire
des toiles d'araignées pour
contenir ce type d'explosion.
Un ingénieur québécois
y travaille.
- (journaliste):
Depuis des millions d'années,
l'araignée peaufine sa technique
de chasse. Sa toile est
à la fois légère et capable
d'encaisser un choc violent,
sans échapper la proie.
Un exploit qui a inspiré
l'ingénieur Frédérick Gosselin.
- Bien, à la base, on a beaucoup
d'applications en génie où on
cherche à faire la même chose
que l'araignée, c'est-à-dire
attraper quelque chose au vol.
La toile d'araignée, elle fait
deux choses. Donc, d'une part,
elle va intercepter l'insecte
qui vient frapper dedans.
Mais d'autre part, elle va
aussi dissiper beaucoup
d'énergie parce qu'on veut
pas que la toile d'araignée
soit comme un trampoline,
puis qu'elle renvoie à l'insecte
de l'autre côté. Il faut que
toute l'énergie de l'impact
soit absorbée et dissipée
par la structure.
- Le secret est dans
la structure même de la soie
d'araignée. L'idée,
c'est d'obtenir les mêmes
performances, avec un plastique.
♪ ♪ ♪
Pour y arriver, Frédérick
Gosselin et son équipe
se servent d'une imprimante 3D,
mais de la mauvaise façon :
en la forçant à éjecter trop
de plastique, trop vite.
- Typiquement, ce qu'on cherche
à faire en impression 3D,
c'est vraiment contrôler
le plus précisément possible
la déposition du matériau.
Nous, ce qu'on vient faire,
c'est le contraire.
C'est qu'on vient céder
à cette instabilité-là,
au filament qui vient danser
dans tous les sens.
Bien, ça nous permet de faire
des formes complexes qui
seraient très difficiles à coder
puis à fabriquer nous-mêmes.
- Ces formes, ce sont
des filaments de plastique,
qui s'entortillent.
À chaque boucle, le fil se soude
légèrement sur lui-même.
Ce sont les liens sacrificiels,
un des mécanismes qui
vont dissiper l'énergie.
Lors d'un impact,
la fibre doit s'étirer.
Le lien sacrificiel se brise.
C'est là qu'entre en action,
un deuxième mécanisme :
la longueur cachée.
Le segment de fibre, qui
n'avait pas encore été exposé,
se met à résister à l'étirement,
un peu comme un ressort.
- Ce qu'on a démontré, en fait,
c'est que la majeure partie
de l'énergie sert, en fait,
à venir déformer la boucle
pour la rendre droite, lorsqu'on
vient appliquer le chargement.
Donc, c'est pas tant le lien
sacrificiel qui est important
dans nos fibres, c'est vraiment
la longueur cachée.
Donc, c'est l'addition d'un
grand nombre de petites boucles
qu'il faut venir redresser
puis étirer toutes ensemble.
Et c'est là où va toute
l'énergie.
- Ces fibres forment une sorte
de treillis qui est ensuite
intégré dans une matrice
de plastique, pour former
une pellicule transparente.
- Pour vérifier ces
performances, chaque échantillon
est solidement fixé.
On place au-dessus un impacteur
de plus d'un demi-kilo
et on filme la suite avec
une caméra haute vitesse.
On teste tour à tour
un plastique uniforme
puis un treillis droit
plus traditionnel et celui
développé par l'équipe.
Il réussit à dissiper plus
de 95 % de l'énergie et,
surtout, à retenir l'impacteur.
- Lorsqu'on venait impacter
une feuille de polymère
uniforme, bien, les dommages
étaient très circonscrits.
C'est-à-dire qu'on avait
vraiment une fissure circulaire
tout le tour de la forme
de l'impacteur, puis
l'impacteur passait au travers
de notre matériau.
Avec notre composite, on a cette
idée-là de longueur cachée qui
doit être déployée, des liens
sacrificiels qui doivent être
brisés. On a les fibres qui vont
avoir tendance à vouloir briser,
sortir de la matrice.
Donc, on a vraiment le dommage
qui va être distribué partout
dans le matériau. Et donc, c'est
comme ça que notre matériau
réussit à venir dissiper
toute l'énergie de l'impact.
- À terme, cette pellicule
pourrait être intégrée
à des vitres pare-balles
ou encore au boîtier qui
entoure les moteurs d'avion.
Parce qu'il arrive qu'un moteur
explose en plein en vol, comme à
Denver, au Colorado, en février.
Il faut donc tester les moteurs,
pour y résister.
Ici, à plein régime,
on fait décrocher une partie
de l'hélice. Quand le moteur
explose, le boîtier doit
retenir tous les débris.
- Ça, ça va se faire avec une
grande énergie de tout le moteur
qui tourne à pleine vitesse.
Et donc, c'est critique.
Et donc, c'est même très normé.
Il faut s'assurer qu'aucune
pièce va transpercer
la carlingue ou une aile
de l'avion. Donc, ça prend
un matériau qui est à la fois
très tenace pour dissiper toute
l'énergie de cette explosion-là,
mais aussi un matériau qui est
très léger parce que ça vole
avec l'avion à tous les jours.
- En miniaturisant les boucles,
on pourrait les imprimer
directement à l'intérieur des
boîtiers de moteurs d'avion
pour remplacer les matériaux
utilisés en ce moment.
Mais l'objectif de Frédérick
Gosselin, c'est d'abord
d'explorer de nouvelles
approches pour créer
les matériaux de demain.
- C'est un changement
de philosophie, c'est-à-dire
que, en ingénierie, on a
tendance à vouloir faire les
choses pour pas que ça brise,
mais du moment où ça brise,
bien, ça brise de façon
catastrophique, tout s'effondre,
tout s'écroule, tout brise
en éclats. Nous ce qu'on a fait,
en fait, c'est qu'on a essayé
de planifier comment
notre matériau allait briser.
Donc, on l'a conçu pour qu'il
se brise d'une certaine façon,
en distribuant l'énergie
et puis en finissant
son travail d'attraper
l'impacteur jusqu'à la fin.